so for those of you who have come and
slightly later we are picking up
something that we've looked at earlier
in the year under algebra so as I as you
can see by the question written on the
board I'm going straight to the jugular
I'm not going to spend any time on like
those those came quadratic disguises
what we used to call them and what I
still call them we're going to go
straight from one which is a little more
challenging and reminds a little more of
that sort of extended knowledge okay so
the whole premise here is we're going to
work with these equations but what we're
going to get or what we're going to
start with doesn't look like a quadratic
but eventually we'll get something which
does and we can use all the knowledge we
already possess about quadratics okay so
the first thing when you notice this
question is that it doesn't fit the nice
the simplest form of an equation
reducible to a quadratic when I talk
about simplest form I mean things like
this that's a lot of quadratic but it's
very easy to replace with a quadratic
you just have to choose a suitable
substitution what would you choose in
this case yeah let let a more you or K
or whatever you're pretty rule of choice
let it be equal to x squared and then
what you'll get is something like this K
squared plus 5 K plus 6 and then off you
go
okay we've seen versions like this we've
seen versions retreat sort of tucked in
there like a side squared X plus 5 sine
X plus 6 etc but then you look at
something like this and you're like oh
wow if you know where do I go there's
this simple thing that you can
substitute in all three of those that
will just make it all collapse okay
so therefore we sort of need to go a
little bit back to the drawing board
come in crimson
excuse me just just come in just commish
I'll cut it later and I'll wait a wait
for awkward later Michael
Michael nice need to join us hurry up
that's why I'm standing fish okay yeah
it's fine I know where she's gonna go no
I'm not it's okay I know where she's
going
give me a little bit of credit um so as
I said we're going back to the drawing
board on this no simple substitution is
going to be our first step what can we
possibly do that could make this a
little bit simpler any suggestions
okay squaring seems like an obvious
strategy to take because I'm for square
roots okay so let's see what happens if
I do that I'll start with the right-hand
side that looks a bit easier to do with
when I square that I'm going to end up
with so that's okay
that looks good but then when you get to
squaring this this is going to become a
well this is a binomial isn't it there's
two terms right we know if you square a
plus B you don't just get a squared plus
B squared what do you get good so
there's this middle bit which is kind of
awkward turn if you're riding along with
me you're going to get a squared plus 2a
v earth plus b squared okay now as it
turns out this is not the only place
that something like this will turn up
later on when we have a look at this
topic called locus this is later this
term and next term as well you're going
to get equations that look like this
they look disastrous you get all these
square roots popping up because every
time you evaluate a distance in
coordinate geometry you get a square
root right that's from Pythagoras so
this is not just a brainchild of someone
who likes to make messy looking
questions this does actually have it so
now what was that a bad idea should I
have done something else because often
you know you go you attempt a problem
and you try something you're like oh
that's that turn back I don't wanna go
in that direction or a team or is this
irredeemable like do I need to try
something else from the first line sure
I do any suggestions
move these guys over this side
you made this slide here okay so hold on
I will come to this in a second before I
answer that question I want to rewind
and I will come back to this line you
know in circle geometry we've done this
before right particularly in circle
geometry you start looking at this egg
or that angle and you're like oh I came
out with zero equals zero you get stuck
right see like I have to try some other
strategy should I try something else
from this slide that's my question
this is an important step by the way
because if I just tell you what you need
to do now that you don't flex that
muscle that says wait is this really the
way to go which is a very important
muscle to flex the D do a suggestion
could I divide let's have a look this
top line here is there anything I can
divide it by that would make this a bit
simpler because it what could I divide
by what might be useful
hmm
the lesson is turn up on time hurry up
see us question
we tried squaring and we all ended up
with that and it didn't look like what
we wanted
what could we divide by them might be
useful square root final equation
divided through by this yeah so if I did
divide through by this then I'm going to
get this on square root of 5x plus 6
this on square root of 5x minus 6 is
that better is it worse hmm
I probably say it's about the same it's
about the same now what I'm trying to
get you toward because we distinguish
should be exercising problems in in
mathematics right and exercise is you've
got you've got 50 of these you know
exactly what to do go ahead and do it 50
times right and then practice that
muscle and get quick and accurate at
what we call fluency right exercise is a
good they have their place and then you
have problems where you it's not obvious
what you need to do you don't know what
the steps are yet I'm about to turn this
problem into an exercise once we're at
the end of this you'll know what to do
but the time when it's a problem is
actually much more useful because you
have to think harder do you notice that
no matter what you do with these you can
divide through you can you can ship
these all over on one side right if I
had three square roots on that side
would I have something better or worse
and actually something worse because I'm
still gonna have to square somewhere and
then you've got something worth for the
binomial to square that you have like a
trinomial that's going to be disastrous
okay there's no way you can rearrange
these things such that when you square
you don't get two square roots okay so
all that just to say this doesn't look
nice at the moment but we had no other
choice like this is literally the best
option and we can recover from here we
can can we do anything to the left-hand
side right now good to fly it have a
look at it
sure we can do something right
okay these guys can go together if we so
choose and these guys can also go
together in a different way we can
collect like terms okay I'm going to go
for that second option in a second as
you'll see briefly there's not heaps of
an advantage to putting these together
excellence for X - to click like toast
42 X plus 3 and then you've got this guy
hanging out over here yes and you've got
a right headphone is there something
else you can do to make this simpler in
an easy way
think of easy things you can do it's
early in the morning isn't it surely
surely I can collect like terms again
right so I'm going to subtract add
subtract yes
so that leaves me with this let's have a
look equals this this yep okay it's only
the money for me - okay now have a look
at this this looks bad but it's still
workable remember that thing you did in
the first life
you thought instinctively I should
square because I have square roots right
and that's good you improve things a
little bit well you can do it you can do
it again country look you've all got the
you don't have a binomial anymore on the
left-hand side so you can square that
quite easily one two three terms 4x plus
5x minus 2 this is why I didn't bother
expanding them just yet and what do you
on the right-hand side yeah so this is I
can I can go ahead and do this kind of
what's this going to be this will be 9x
squared minus 27 X so minus 54 X plus
any one okay now I will pause there I
will pause there because what have we
done we transformed and we not
transferred a problem into an exercise
you know what to do with this don't you
so I'm going to give you a few minutes
to catch up and do that as you do that I
want to wake make one
warning okay where do we progress from
y1 to line five okay you squared + u
squared twice did you notice that okay
now when you square you change the
equation that you're working with right
for example suppose I gave you this
equation this equation here how many
solutions do you expect there to be -
what about this equation I square both
sides we tend to get more and more
solutions as we get higher powers of X
if you notice that right under there any
solutions actually I can think about how
many extensions they're added to this
not that important my point is watch out
because you've changed this problem okay
I'm not going to give you any more clues
than that I just want you to be
conscious of that you have five lines if
you haven't already popped them down
see where you can go up here